now you're each gonna camp on a  different Island by yourself three days  and three nights look around you to your  own slice of paradise  hey wait can you at least tell me your  name stay close to the fire so how long  have you been here for since I was  little  were there other people here too just my  mother you can't ever go through here  okay she'll kill you if she finds you I  was supposed to pick me up  she's dead I found her boat shipwrecked  I saw your mother  I think she killed her they see these  things at night these terrible things at  night she's stuck here just like us  let's just get out of here while we  still can  I have to help her  [Music]  you have no idea what you're doing  it's always here  [Music]  [Music]  you